[Music]
well with a title like that I want you
to take a wild guess what this game is
about that's right
talking through your problems and
befriending all of God's creatures and
discovering the healing power of love
just kidding it's murderer this is the
glorious game I've ever played when you
name it splatter house I'd be
disappointed with anything less this
game is a modern reboot of a classic
arcade title much in the same light as
Doom 3 or recent Mortal Kombat's sadly I
never got to play those classic arcade
games being that I'm young dumb and full
subscribers thanks everybody I can't
express enough in words how much I
appreciate all of you thank you but
enough kissing up to my lovely followers
let's get down to it
this game is written by comic writer
Gordon Rennie who is known for Judge
Dredd Negron odds predator nemesis sewer
patrol and tons of other comics you've
probably never heard of see I don't even
have to do research I guess is look in
the back of the box and I love the
dialogue and story in this game we start
with a pair of college kids entering a
spooky mansion for reasons to be
determined later and there soon greeted
by a creepy mad scientist as well as a
horde of monsters
our main character Rick the hipster is
impaled while his girlfriend is
kidnapped by the evil dr. West
Rick's lifeless body falls into a
display case and unleashes an ancient
evil known only as the mask after
putting on the mask is a last-ditch
effort to save his life Rick succumbs to
the power of his new John Cena bod and
becomes a Titan of pure punching power
thus we begin a ride of punching more
punching even more punching which
graduates stabbing then to smashing and
we end on shooting all this to save
Rick's girlfriend Jen man this looks
tiring so Rick in the mask are both
pretty interesting characters actually
the mask is a mischievous demon that
thrives on blood and chaos cut it out
then find more things for us to kill
blood and carnage always make me feel
more cooperative
he makes inappropriate jokes says poetic
things about mass murder and
Lovecraftian horror is rising from the
abyss they are everything and nothing
they inhabit the abyss the gulf between
one send understood the place from
whence stems all human suffering their
famine conflict genocide they are now
and forever amen and they're coming your
way and breaks the fourth wall showing
why we call it splatter house this
character couldn't be more perfect if
they tried to top it all off he's voiced
by Jim Cummings also known as we need
the Pooh and Darkwing Duck Jesus right
get it together I asked you to trust me
first sight of blood your cry like a
school
for a dick my childhood is vastly
improved speaking of Rick is a
kind-hearted geek who wouldn't hurt a
fly are the human used to be a long time
ago
weak stomach but he's pushed into this
crazy journey in which he becomes a
blood fuelled maniac that murders demons
and hordes of the undead by the planet
load the mask is having a pretty good
time with all this but our relatable
hero Rick very clearly just wants to go
home and no you're hearing that right
this is Josh Keaton my favorite voice
actor of the spectacular spider-man
series and if you want to get really
obscure he's also revolver ocelot that
one's for you Jackson this is an
incredibly talented voice cast and the
two halves of our player character make
this game so much better than if he was
just silent the whole time
the back and forth is always interesting
and the game covers themes like atoning
for one sins and the ethics of killing
to save another a lot of implications
are made about the origins of the
antagonist throughout you have to
collect all these audio logs to really
get a full picture of what's going on
I also need to take note of the heavy
metal soundtrack by Five Finger Death
Punch Mastodon land God and the plasmas
the only thing missing was slipknot I
love this soundtrack so most of the
music in this video will be from it
unless YouTube's not okay with that I
don't know we'll see what happens now
you may be wondering when I'll talk
about the gameplay which for a lot of
people is the main attraction and to
that I respond right now it's a pretty
standard character action game or
spectacle fighter for you anal retentive
folk but it manages to keep itself from
getting boring by mixing it up so often
every level has something new like for
example you can't pass this area unless
you kill all the enemies in a specific
way or here you can't slow down to fight
because the ceiling keeps caving in hell
in this place the ground keeps opening
up and a giant spinning fan blades
designed to grind up bodies and you have
to stay clear of it the varying
environments and enemy patterns keep it
from feeling repetitive and did I
mention this game was gory well Rick can
do fatalities call him finishing moves
if will help you sleep at night but
they're just fatalities the entire area
goes dark and you have to follow certain
inputs to finish the enemies and
cartoonishly bloody ways there's a lot
of these animations across all the
game's enemy types but they do raise the
question of whether Rick is that same to
begin with given these circumstances I
could see a normal person tearing a
monster's head off with their newfound
superpowers but ripping its head in half
and pulling out its lungs and slamming
them into the ground that's a bit much
still within the realm of reason though
then we get to the savage disembowelling
through their anus holy [ __ ] Rick's
settle down see that's the kind of [ __ ]
that got us an M rating oh and you can
pick up weapons too the weapon selection
is pretty similar to The Last of Us
wooden board lead pipe machete
the only thing Joel didn't pick up was a
chainsaw and this game makes them
exactly as powerful as you want them to
be you hit someone with a pipe and they
go flying you slice someone in half with
a meat cleaver they turn to bits after
one hit the power and the weapons makes
you want to think strategically about
how you'll use them going into a fight
because there is weapon degradation so
you'll start hacking up the toughest
enemy in a room with the blade dispose
of it in a spectacularly violent fashion
and then use your strongest power on all
the goons left behind but I'll get that
this character is powered by monster
blood not unlike the guy from
blood-borne though this came out first
and has way more fun with the concept
you have Wolverine style healing powers
that are activated by consuming blood so
you'll find yourself trying to find the
biggest puddles of it in combat look at
this place it's like Hannibal Lecter's
house after a dinner party you can also
actively drain blood from enemies by
pressing a trigger button and hammering
circle or beam this stops all the
enemies and their tracks long enough for
you to fully heal yourself at the cost
of one bar of your meter if you keep
battering bad guys your meter fills up
and you can turn on mask mode well the
mass takes over and Rick becomes even
more badass as he cuts enemies to
ribbons I also love how you become the
same size as any of the bosses in this
mode well most of them anyway what a
great segue the bosses are awesome eat
your heart out Resident Evil my favorite
is probably the first one which is this
doll that can telekinetically move
objects around itself to create a suit
of armor out of pieces of scenery from
the house this fight involves you
ripping this huge enemy apart whatever
way you can it's one of the highlights
of the game alongside the chainsaw
wielding demon that teleports when the
lights are off by the way this game
often pays respect to its arcade roots
with side-scrolling sections that
amazingly don't kill the flow of the
game these are actually pretty cool and
more interesting than just walking down
a straight hallway the way you normally
would and they do a lot of cool tricks
with the three-dimensional perspective
ooh
collectibles
what's this okay so rips girlfriend
leaves torn pictures of herself as a
trail so he can find her but some of
these pictures are pretty tame and
others are whoa well I well you know I
mean being a perfectionist and all I'm
sure there's an achievement for getting
every single this Games's exhales now
I'm in him refrigerator - camera isn't
focusing enough on Rick's and triggered
look all of those are valid arguments
but I refute them on the grounds a [ __ ]
you chainsaw fight and special guest
appearance by Cthulhu trapped in a giant
fish tank I wish I could fight him but
what are you gonna do and he's got his
own stuff going on in life right now he
seems busy
I'm sure if someone was a fan of those
old arcade games you may be impressed
with all the changes or disappointed
that it just isn't the same well fear
not this game much like doom 3 BFG
edition contains ports of all the
original games that led up to this one
so if you want to take a fun nostalgic
trip you could totally do that no I
won't review the side scroller games
because I'm bad at them I suck at old
games don't ask me why but if it's
before the ps1 I'm bad at it I can't
even play megaman it's throwing that of
course I have to talk about the stuff
that I don't like in the game - there
are these segments when they want you to
do some uncharted style climbing
sequences and the system for doing them
is very clunky and almost always takes
multiple tries to do failing them is
annoying because the checkpoints are
sort of unforgiving and while this game
isn't too hard dying a few times from
something really cheap is sort of
inevitable
[Music]
[Music]
the loading times are also sort of long
but I'm forgiving to that sort of thing
because this game is six years old after
all the fatality animations are awesome
at all but there's only so many of them
they can make and you might start
getting bored of them after seeing the
same for used over and over again
eventually you start wanting them to go
faster then you get to this mindset
where you're okay with them as long as
you get to do something while they
happen like lean over and drink a soda
or check a text message while it
finishes there also isn't much variation
in the enemy types
you essentially fight the same ten enemy
types over and over and they just get
bigger and tougher as it goes something
that isn't really a flaw but definitely
a turn-off for some people is the fact
that this game is incredibly difficult
towards the end enemies that are used as
bosses in the earlier levels return just
as average enemy types and it can start
to feel a little overwhelming when you
have so many giant monsters to fight at
once I mean look at this these enemies
do damage to you when you touch them but
there isn't any weapons in the room and
your health is just worn down by two
bosses simultaneously it's not
impossible but damn is it a challenge if
you're one of those Dark Souls
masochists I highly suggest you crank
this [ __ ] - the hardest difficulty and
give it a shot oh come on really there's
so much everything happening thankfully
these are my biggest complaints and it's
a solid game despite them it's okay I
handled it so without spoiling the story
too much it takes you to a lot of
locations across time and space
[Music]
the early levels have a great haunted
house vibe and the later ones give you
this glimpse into the creepiest
post-apocalypse I've seen in a long time
as well as a horror themed amusement
park and some looks into a cracked
version of reality I won't give away
details because I really want you to
play this for yourself but the ending
just begs for a sequel that sadly never
got made I'm sorry to report that the
entire development team was laid off
from Namco Bandai shortly after the
game's release and this one flew pretty
far under the radar for the gaming world
further ruining this game's chances at a
follow-up so many people haven't heard
of this game and that's a tragedy if
I've ever seen one
your nutsacks not infused to your chin
right I consider that a successful trend
I say this game is an underrated gem of
the action genre and if this sort of
thing is your cup of tea go pick up a
copy and check it out this games neato
unless you're a no-fun Daniel do-gooder
who is shocked by bad language in which
case just go play Wolverine Origins no
one cusses in that game it's weird can
never forget your first kill oh oh these
things hurt oh I'm sorry did your vagina
just say something